my guest tonight was of course a cast
member on saturday night live and
starred in numerous films including
the wayne's world movies please welcome
uh my very good friend
and uh good god one of the funniest
people ever dana carvey
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah how are you thank you so much it's
so important to me that uh that you
could be here
i would never have missed it that's
impossible you know you turned to sound
a couple times no i'm kidding you didn't
i saw conan and greg daniels come into
snl
1980 you were right out of 1988 it was
just yeah
we were out of high school you guys are
standing there like this i was
pretty big on the show at that time you
were a huge star and i'll never forget
you walked into the room
and my writing partner and i were we're
standing there like this yeah
and uh you came in and um you could not
have been nicer you couldn't have been
nicer to us i was a good actor
in those days
i i saw you fresh-faced guys and i
thought well okay they seem all right
and then i went to lauren's office and
what's up he goes
uh i don't think it's gonna end well
you guys are awesome and greg daniels
never had an office
isn't that bizarre yeah yeah he created
the office of the american office come
on
come on i got nothing yeah
i like a guy who starts his segment by
saying come on i got nothing
i'm just trying to think is there any
comedian that can go from zero to 300
like you
because you're just like really calm in
the ball right i mean you burst
harder i burst hard yeah yeah i've been
controlled
oh come on this is a show
by children four children knock it off
we're perfect
i remember it one time i was in the
makeup chair you're doing your show and
i saw on the monitor
you doing the monologue and all i could
see from the side was what the time was
one of the hardest i've ever laughed i
mean it was like two i don't know what
you were
the sound was off it was just the guys
a lot of desperation a lot of commitment
i always wanted it to be funny if the
sound wasn't on i i that was something i
used to think about
funny and funny with kit like little
kids i work so hard with little kids
yeah you go to a house and there's
little kids there
i work real hard and there'll be like
two and they're laughing and i'll say to
my wife i got him and she's like it's
sad so
it's funny sound off by the way i don't
really get a chance much i'm sort of
launching a new
podcast right now could i just do a
quick thing you can cut it later it's
called kicking it with andy
[Laughter]
how's it kicking it's kicking great man
it's really kicking great that's great
um i have one with you too
this is kind of how it is now isn't it
yeah yeah you can cut it out it's just i
don't get an
audience and stuff this just let me just
get a shot on myself here we're gonna
um this is called the best you have to
come with conan o'brien
well i'll just anyway i got the
instagram teaser yeah you guys
put that down hey you know i know you're
always we talk about it we hang out uh
yeah wishes but we have boozy three-hour
dinners we do
uh and um you've been uh you're always
working on the next thing i know you've
been
for you worked on your biden yeah in
case he became president he did and you
have a very good you have some good
observations as an impressionist
tell us about biden fine yeah biden well
i watched him dirt when he's doing the
town hall
and that's where i kind of got him
because he would walk around with the
microphone really slow
yeah my father you know lost his job no
kidding not joking around
there's nothing funny at all about his
dad losing his job but is it
my dog died i'm not kidding around
joe i found a severed head no joke no
kid around
that was the first hook no joke i'm not
kidding around here man
and then i noticed he made lists number
one the one part number two the thing
number three you know the drill
because he gets confused and then he
kind of turns on the audience come on
isn't rocket science
i mean i beat up a guy you know named
corn pop
i beat him up corn pop pop pop popcorn
jiffy pop anyway
excuse me children of the corn so those
were the three homes did you see
he biden just met did you i just met
with putin oh yeah
that you know to me putin is like is an
interesting idea of a dictator who's
gonna be there for 30 years talk a new
guy might be gone in two years
yeah so he's like it's just he's like
the guy who swallowed the cat right oh
it's our electoral system people calm
down
yeah and putin is just so smooth with it
now you just had trump a minute ago
no now he's got him
you know so he's like
[Laughter]
and the interpreter is like we're going
to keep our ballistic missiles in the
ukraine and biden's like come on
come on get your facts straight jack
let's do something
come on i'll take you out behind the
woodshed and beat the hell out of you
i was talking to you uh it was the day
it was the day after
the obamas signed a netflix deal yeah
and i just happened to i think we got
lunch or something
and you were just tickled to death that
the obamas were going to be working with
netflix
and you started making me laugh so hard
talking about it
do you remember where we were pitching
movies and stuff i i do obama a lot of
my podcasts i just have
i just love his i love i love the
character
of a guy kind of is that cool that calm
you can just kind of
sum things up that's all and if you
so he i had the idea i go to netflix
just to meet with them i would love to
pitch him but i assume he
might have an idea for me because he's
new then i got an idea before you start
i don't know it's a half hour show i
think it's um it's about guys in a bar
and they're all friends it's called uh
here's to you
i go i think that's cheers oh me
michelle
[Applause]
and i always have him yelling at
michelle michelle he didn't like it
didn't want it
i got another one okay that one didn't
work this one's a big boat sinks i'm
calling it gigantic
i think that's titanic oh hey michelle
he didn't like it
leave the egg salad out on the table
i'll eat it when i get to it
so i just do him a lot i love i love the
cadence he's got that great
that that that's kind of everything you
know you say things are going good
you got to be happy that's right conan
o'brien there you go
[Laughter]
andy richter enough said that's it
that's all you got to be you don't have
to try to be anything other than what
you are
america appreciates and loves the two of
you
i feel i feel better yeah thank you mr
president
yeah well yeah that's the thing is there
are different kinds of impressionists
and some go for incredible accuracy and
you do this thing where you
you're kind of interested in accuracy
and rhythm but you're more interested
in stretching it out yeah which is the
kind of impressions i've always loved to
see people do
you you almost stretch it out like silly
putty until it becomes
almost it's not quite the person but
you're capturing something it's kind of
like
your arnold was became the well that's
only i i just watched you doing arnold
but we both
blew it out to this yeah just give me
your quick art like
one three sausages
sausage you eat it because i i would and
it was just
it became there were no words i want to
see that face from this club
there were no words at a certain point
yeah i saw him once and he did
he had nothing to say and we bumped into
each other and i was having coffee
ah coffee in the morning i was like yeah
i'm having kyle
it's good for you he's got caffeine to
wake you up
but it was crazy i just i do him as mr
positive because he never goes negative
i remember
he we had a movie that didn't do well at
one point and they're interviewing him
on the today show or something like they
didn't get the box i know it's fantastic
let me tell you people are enjoying it
all over the world but it was lower than
the other ones yeah but everybody's
great
you're fantastic i'm fantastic
everything's fantastic
and when he was governor there'd be a
fire and he would come out and there was
a fire force fire
and the the fire police and the firemen
came to it with the hoses
they came with the horses and they
sprayed the water
and the fire's like get out of here i
don't like this because
the other thing uh is you and i have
wasted more hours of our life
doing uh beetles doing you love to do
we're
uh obsessed we're obsessed we're both
obsessed with it and uh we both
like to play guitar and we both know all
those songs we know everything
we know way too much about it but then
you will start talking about
as mccartney and you'll do mccartney
describing what's going on in the world
i
i like to visit the beetley voice uh
when things are dark
because i don't think you can you could
take almost any news story
and filter it through the b league paul
mccartney liverpudlian colloquialisms
and it comes out more positive
right just think of any story anybody in
the audience any
story that's kind of dark or not uh
the pandemic well you know it's you know
this little thing came around you know
this little thing it's a little thingy
and it sneaks in your body you know
but the good news is we came up with a
with a vaccina
you know we got a jabber we got a jabber
and what that does is you know it goes
in your body and it
tells the cells to make themselves all
spiky so they look like a corona virus
you know
i've seen you i'll see you around here
again i know what to do
so it makes you it makes me so happy
yeah yeah suddenly it's not so scary
we got a jabba we got a jabba
you used to do uh you once were doing
mccartney explaining to
uh lennon and and like lennon's up in
heaven and he checks in with paul every
now and then and he's explaining
to mccartney is trying to explain rap
and rap stars kanye west and lenin
doesn't understand what mccartney is
talking about that came from really
always wanting john lennon and paul
mccartney to to hook up and talk about
how brilliant they were together you
know so i just did it for my own
amusement
but it's like how you doing paul i'm
doing fine john how are you
that's great you know how's it going
down there who's great who made a record
with the kanye west you know who's
who's the kanye
[Laughter]
he's west talky singer you know does he
have a good gal behind him i heard yoko
yeah he's got a great gal by the network
used to wait a minute this bit's two
years old
[Laughter]
okay i'll adapt on the fly he had a nice
girl but she's you know she flew the
coop you know but she had a
she's uh she's really terrific what did
she do well she's a sort of a you know
she takes pictures of a bottom
[Laughter]
what do you mean it's not a normal
bottom john it's a bottom 2.0
it's like it's like god made a fanny and
attached a person as an afterthought
it was 2019 it's a little dated now
it's good stuff though i have to say i
have to say you do uh
yeah but i think my all-time favorite
impression of yours was jimmy stewart
and i used to think that's an impression
that everyone knows because no matter
how many years go by people still watch
it's a wonderful life he's it's the you
know
that was kind of the first impression i
ever wanted to learn
you know and we didn't have tape
recorders then basically so i was
with my friends in a volkswagen bug in
in 1975 and they were stoned
and it's it started to hit me i started
to do it and i started to be able to
talk like him you know
and this is true story they went into a
jack-in-the-box and we're in there and
then i went through the drive-through
and they said they said i want to take
an order this true story and i said yeah
yeah
i'd like a jumbo jack with cheese
and the guy thought it was jimmy stewart
or pretended to say hey is this jimmy
stewart after
a bit more of that so that became a
thing and uh
when i was on deep dive with you on your
podcast yeah
we did do you guys know jimmy stewart is
from it's a wonderful life yeah
you get a thing where he's he's in the
car
he's in a he's sitting in a car with uh
i guess katherine hepburn
yeah and uh they're doing an illicit
kind of oral
sexual activity sure and jimmy stewart
like i don't like things that are
overtly sexual but just him in that
situation with his vernacular would be
like yeah
well take your time
[Laughter]
no reason to rush it
well just look at it for a bit yeah now
now look away
we'll flip in the other direction now
look back at it and act surprised
so it just goes on and on was crying and
then i was calling my
brothers and doing it for them on the
phone not
you know i couldn't do that but doing
the same thing yeah i just
i just loved it it was just the voice is
so good and it makes me believe that
that's happening
that was always like when i was working
at clubs in the early days and just
hells angels and drunk people and
bombing like crazy
jimmy stewart as a waiter never didn't
save my act
like i'd be just tanking jimmy stewart
as a waiter
was always a go-to like yeah well can i
take your order
well what do you mean you don't know the
specials i told them to you 10 minutes
ago
what do you want me to stand here like a
trained monkey and tell them to you
again
but what what'd you say well you
i've never failed never failed
uh i i have a new character
oh you have a new you have a new
character
sometimes uh really bad things stick
with people i have no idea why
this was just a notion of uh like i like
to do like bad
stand-ups this guy's name red red neckie
the redneck comedian
okay and the jokes are intentionally
terrible and he has a catchphrase so see
if it amuses you i don't know
intentionally bad comedy um this is my
second to last show
and you're trying out
on a piece of paper
well this this looks like a suicide note
you rip it out
i played this theater a few times and i
came out like look at this bit look at
that bit
and it never really worked so i
discovered that the largo theater
yes experimental theater yes but i
saved it i was gonna work this out
someplace really uh you know a small
club stuff but i thought let's do it on
one of conan's final show
so because i want to just try out
this is red rednecky red red neckie the
redneck comedian intentionally bad you
ever crap so big you don't know gonna go
down that turlet
come and get some crazy
is that his catchphrase come and get
come and get some let's go
i met my sister only cause mama turned
me down
come and get some
this is scaring me because this would do
very well in some places
it surprisingly does well i asked my
mama what's for dinner she says roadkill
i said what kind she says i gotta take a
drive come and get some
[Laughter]
my grandpa invented the phrase dollars
to doughnuts every time i got a buck he
bought a donut he died at 37.
come and get song
you know you need to hear him yeah this
one's a little emotional my mama asked
me what's your dream red i said
living in a shack and drinking beer all
day she said don't dream too big cause
you always end up disappointed
come again songs
[Laughter]
a little souvenir i'm coming get some
humming it's um
i want to say until you started trying
out it was an honor
having you here i was trying out the
whole time
you are i met you i i don't know i was
24 years old 24 years old
uh you were the funniest person uh then
and still to this day you make me laugh
so hard and you're a brilliant man and
you're a very nice guy
and you coming on my show all these
times over the years
if you told me in 88 when i first met
you it's amazing someday conan you'll
have a show and this guy will come on
and he'll waste time on your second to
last show
that's good that wasn't boring then you
know you saw someone
but let me come right back at you you uh
when you started and then you were a
writer primarily on the show
and i kept hearing conan's the funniest
guy in the writer's room
you know but then i'd be around you and
you'd be a little shy i was quiet around
uh talent yeah i would do little voices
come on you know
and then eventually you became the
funniest guy in america
well i wouldn't say that
i'll take nine i mean i'm happy to be
nine well
no no one no one's no one in
in in the last 30 years has done this
much comedy that's this good i don't
think
it's volume and i mean uh i didn't know
we get this serious but really i mean
there's only as funny as you there's no
funnier than you
and you and andy no one has a sidekick
you know relationship like this
yeah because andy will just lay you out
with the subtlest things out of nowhere
yeah and conan will be very sweet as pie
and then explode into this comedy part
and this nice audience is seeing that
you know this this thing we've had
together all these years and we've
become really really good friends
we really have and uh i love you and i
thank you so much for being here
and uh uh let's talk to our we have we
share our therapist
we share a therapist but not that's not
a joke not at the same time and at the
same time
but most of my sessions are about my
relationship with congress yeah yeah
and i try to get him and i uh every now
and then i'd be like dana uh
she'll be like she'll she will i won't
give her name but she will say like
how's it going i'll be like well
you know doing a little better than dana
i'm probably not supposed to disclose
that but i think it's hilarious that you
and i have the same therapist
howard stern i told him and he was very
upset about that oh that's just wrong
you should have your own therapist you
know that's just terrible oh
she's fantastic she is fantastic you're
fantastic i'm fantastic
[Music]